[Music]
we can never get enough of Disney
Princesses and once again talented
artists reimagined our favorite
characters miriam Safdar and andrew Pena
recreated pictures of the princesses and
other characters as Japanese cartoons
and we have to admit that they look even
more beautiful and funnier than the
originals just wait until you see what
Aurora looks like when she is sleeping
if this is your first time visiting our
channel don't forget to subscribe and
please give this video a big thumbs up
today we are showing you 15 Disney
Princesses reimagined as anime Rapunzel
the prince who spent 18 years alone in a
tower trapped by a witch and that's a
shame for everyone who didn't get a
chance to see how beautiful and kind the
young girl was that is until Flynn Ryder
into her room and gave her the
opportunity to discover the outside
world but because we can never get
enough of her Meriam Safdar imagined her
as an anime character and the princess
is even more beautiful now that we can
see more details she still has the long
blonde hair and traditional German
purple dress but this time her beautiful
green eyes are shinier and we even see
her freckles and by the look of her face
she is just about to escape her tower
and discover a wonderful world do you
wish you could see anim Rapunzel going
on an adventure Cinderella in this rags
to riches story we had the chance to see
a poor servants become the most
beautiful princess in the kingdom with
the help of a fairy godmother who
dressed her in a beautiful dress the
Prince immediately fell in love with her
so to make sure the princess will be
happy ever after Meriam Safdar recreated
the young woman wearing her most
beautiful outfit as an anime character
her eyes are bright blue and her hair is
a little Messier but she is even more
beautiful with all these added details
she looks even more grown-up now she is
19 years old
draw with this more realistic and
updated look the young woman will be
ready for prom in 2017 do you think she
would be crowned prom queen no matter
what in a fairy tale or real-life
Cinderella would deserve a crown on her
head Alice she might not be a princess
but she looks just like one and this
time she didn't have to wait for a
prince to go on a wonderful adventure
the daydreaming girl followed a rabbit
and ended up in another magical world
and as you can see in this picture from
Miriam Safdar it seems like the little
girl never left Wonderland she is still
holding the White Rabbit in her hands
but this time he looks much more
realistic did she imagine all this or
was this world real no matter what no
one could ever doubt that alice is
really beautiful with her blonde hair
big blue eyes and little blue dress she
looks just like a doll and she can even
be just as small as this toy when she
drinks the potion from a bottle do you
think that Alice should become an
official Disney Princess Jasmine the
Arabian princess is truly a wish come
true
we understand why Aladdin asks for
Jamie's help to win her heart and in
fact she was so beautiful that they had
to make sure the street urchin looks
better than the other Prince's - they
made him older took off his shirt and
made it more confident so do you want to
see the look of the princess who
inspired this Prince here is Jasmine
reimagined by Miriam Safdar she looks so
good as an anime character the colour
she wears are even brighter and her hair
and eyes are shinier Jasmine is just as
precious as a diamond but this artist is
not the only one who imagined this
princess as anime just look at this
artwork from Andrew Pena Jasmine now has
round her eyes a tiny nose and brighter
hair and by the look on her face the
young princess looks really happy to see
Aladdin Ariel
our favorite Little Mermaid's made a man
fall in love with her when she couldn't
even talk with only her beauty to seduce
the prince this girl must be very pretty
and that's exactly how Miriam Safdar
represented her her long red hair looks
so good that she must have brushed them
for hours with the fork how can they be
so shiny after years swimming in the sea
and we totally understand why Eric would
move to kiss the girl with those sweet
lips and if you want to see more or the
mermaid reimagined as anime
here's another creation from Andrew Pena
her look is much more expressive and
instead of red lipstick she's now
wearing a dark eyeliner we would love to
know where she bites her makeup because
we have never seen anything so
waterproof Milan Milan didn't want to
marry a man or become a housewife
instead she became a man and joined the
army this is why it is surprising to see
that Miriam Safdar recreated her as a
feminine character instead of her old
father's armor Mulan is now wearing a
pink and purple kimono dress as when she
was prepping for the matchmaker she even
wears a flower on her head even though
we know that this ornament is too
fragile for her great adventure she
looks like she is ready to meet her
future husband so we think that it won't
last long
soon Mulan will take the place of her
father in the army and pretend to be a
man to become a great warrior of China
take off that kimono a woman needs to
wear something more comfortable she
wants to save her country tiana the girl
didn't mind being the most beautiful of
them all she just wanted to work hard
and have enough money to realize her
dream but isn't this ambition what makes
her look even better as a young waitress
as a princess and even as a frog no man
can resist her Mary and Safdar imagined
her at her best when she is dressed as a
princess green suits her perfectly as a
woman or as an amphibian but we have to
admit that we still love seeing her
working as a waitress - here's how
andrew kenya reimagined her her eyes are
bigger and we love that beautiful smile
Tiana's hair is a little Messier we
don't mind we know that what matters is
not what's on
head for what's in it lectures hope she
will be the one serving our favorite
meal every day and soon it will be in
her own restaurant kiddo
even though she is a princess of
Atlantis most people forget about this
Disney character but this time we pay
homage to this warrior who saved her
city and became a queen now let's take a
look at this artwork from Miriam Safdar
to see if you remember her
the princess is even more beautiful with
all these details in her hair she still
wears a blue pendant around her neck and
the blue makeup on her face but this
time we can see her in a brighter light
to really appreciate her beauty the
creator's didn't want her to be a damsel
in distress like the other princesses
they wanted her to be a warrior like no
other and as you can see from her looks
all these artists succeeded in making
her unique characters series Incubus
deserves to be an official Disney
contest don't be shy to tell us what you
think in the comments down below
Pocahontas the Native American princess
taught John Smith to just look around
him to realize how beautiful nature is
but little did she know the most
gorgeous thing he could see was
Pocahontas standing right in front of
him once again Miriam Safdar made the
princess look even more beautiful than
she is in the original movie we love
those eyes and the high cheekbones and
the character also looks more mature
than what we used to see all the little
details let us discover even more of her
beauty but if you want to see Pocahontas
in the funniest way just look at this
drawing from Andrew benya her eyes are
way bigger than they were before
and Pocahontas now has rosy cheeks is
she shy to see John Smith by the way she
looks at him it just seems like this man
probably said something that didn't
please her once again
Elsa how could we forget Queen Elsa we
will never let it go this is probably
one of the best Disney Princess movies
after hiding her power for years and
trapping her kingdom in a perpetual
winter she discovered that all she
needed
sister to warm her heart and as you can
see from this picture her Miriam Safdar
she received so much love from her
sister that she became a summer queen we
know one little snowman who will be
happy to hear about this with a green
dress covered with pink flowers the
people around her can finally enjoy a
beautiful summer day and we can forget
about her sister Anna she now looks like
the princess of spring with all these
flowers on her dress no matter what we
know that these sisters will stay
together during the four seasons the
warmth and the cold never bothered them
anyway Merida the redhead didn't need a
man to tell her she is beautiful she
already knew she was without making any
effort and what made her prettier is
that she didn't even care about that
Merida had better things to do than
trying to please anyone as you can see
in this drawing from Miriam Safdar the
princess is more beautiful than ever she
kept her natural look with no makeup
wild hair and tons of freckles but this
time don't you think she looks older
than she is in the original film instead
of being 16 she looks like she could be
in her 20 after all you should marry a
man when you're too young but she
doesn't care about them anyway
her heart belongs to herself and no one
will ever keep this brave princess from
being who she wants to be Tinkerbell
the little fairy might not be a princess
but she's still one of our favorite
Disney characters following Peter Pan
everywhere her greatest strength is
making everyone smile and you have to
admit that you want to see what she
looks like as an anime anyway so let's
see how Miriam Safdar imagined her she
kept her bubbly personality but she
looks even prettier when we can take a
closer look at her with all these
details we can truly believe that magic
exists and it is hidden in the forest in
Neverland how can we explain why
Tinkerbell is so gorgeous otherwise
looking so good must be one of her
secret powers don't forget to say that
you believe that fairies exist today we
want this beautiful creature and her
friend
to live forever we believe in fairies
snow-white
mirror mirror on the wall who is the
fairest one of all
it's snow-white of course but not the
one we saw in the original movie the
princess as anime looks even better just
take a look at this artwork from Miriam
shaft are the beautiful teenager looks
even younger now after all she is
supposed to be 14 and this time she
clearly looks like she is Snow White
seems even more innocent without makeup
and with her wavy hair but please
someone tell her not to eat the apple in
her hand and as you can see in this
picture from Andrew Pena someone just
told her that the proof was dangerous
and she looks more shocked than
surprised who could have done that to
her if she thinks about the fact that
her stepmother wanted a hunter to steal
her heart she's probably one of the
primary suspects Aurora if there is one
girl who looks gorgeous when she's
sleeping its Aurora she never expected
that she would fall asleep for days when
she found a spinning mill but she
managed to look so beautiful lying in
bed anyway she looks so great that a
prince couldn't resist the temptation of
kissing her and as you can see in this
picture from Miriam Safdar we would love
to fall in love with her too
just look at these gorgeous blonde locks
and that pretty face the artist even
dared to imagine her with purple eyes
this characteristic is so rare
just as this princess of beauty but it's
time to have a little more fun just
watch what Andrew Pena thought she would
look like as an anime character sleeping
we're not sure if Prince Philip would
like to kiss her right now but but she
would definitely make it a smile now
this is what a real woman would look
like if she spent the whole day sleeping
well with the name like that we could
expect the princess to be the most
beautiful of them all and she truly is
not only on the outside but also on the
inside no other woman could have taken
the time to make the Beast of better man
and turn him into a prince charming but
could you believe that she could be even
prettier than she already is just take a
look at this picture from Miriam Safdar
she
ready for the ball and once the prince
sees her there would be no going back he
won't be able to keep himself from
falling in love with her but now let's
take a look at another version of Belle
from Andrew Pena this time she didn't
take the time to do her hair or do her
makeup and she doesn't even care the
beats will love her as she is or he
won't love her at all and that's it 415
Disney Princesses reimagined as anime
who is your favorite character don't
forget to tell us in the comments and
for more stories like this make sure you
subscribe to our Channel and watch 15
Disney Princesses reimagined by amazing
artists thanks for watching
[Music]
you